like if you choose to go into like a
city in a nightclub like men are
assaulted too men can get punched get
into fights if they're so it's like we
both have problems but more often than
not I'm I mean this is very generalizing
but if a man gets into an altercation
with another man more often than not
this is very generalizing but in the
terms of a situation like in a nightclub
or whatever so say I was in a night club
before two guys got into a fight that
was an altercation between them two like
being men they were fighting they were
arguing it was violent whereas like if
an altercation happened with a woman it
would be because he was such a
inappropriate that she was saying no
stop it and he would get angry because
he couldn't get the way he wanted can I
can I give you a stat that you might not
know yeah so so so so so so let's let's
talk about abusive relationships so most
abusive relationships are or they're
both abusive meaning the man's hitting
the woman and the woman's hitting the
mat but in in cases where it's one-sided
abuse meaning someone's hitting and the
other is not hitting back women do it
more than men okay
so it's like when I see stats like this
and it's still like that women are
impressed like because I really think
men have a hard time coming forward when
they're assaulted by men so so I'll give
you another example tonight I'm here
with Jesse right and Jesse was literally
like we got it on camera this girl was
like pushing him and like all over him
and if that happened to me like I they
would cry assault right but for him like
nobody says anything yeah and so it's
like like girls can kind of get away
with that stuff where guys everyone
agrees it's wrong I do think that's a
hard statistic come by because
realistically like the difference is
even a night she's trying to get girls
to come forward and be like what you're
saying is wrong like you're not really
advocating for women's rights and even
the women are too afraid to come over to
you and talk to you well I don't know
why they're afraid like it's quite like
I don't know
[Music]
yeah because you are personally not even
like am I am I rude to you like I've
been quite polite to me but like to the
women you you have been rude uh how have
I been rude when someone threatened to
punch me okay but I know it hasn't
fashioned trying to punch you yeah but
she said I don't want to be near you
like that's kind of rude right it is
kind of weird but when you're like I'm
asking that hair experience of being
touched in a club where she didn't want
to be touched it's invalid you were
saying oh I didn't I didn't say it was
invalid that's not what I said okay but
you kind of push her away and neglected
it like it's not really an issue like
you wanted to talk about men I'm saying
I'm saying I don't think that's okay I
don't I think that's wrong but when you
go out into a nightclub like you know
there's a possibility that'll happen but
there shouldn't be a possibility I'm
saying I'm saying it happens to men and
women it happens to both like like just
today I went out with Jesse right and I
I was threatened right Jesse protected
me that was a privilege as a woman that
I got this girl comes up to him and has
his hands all over her hands all over
him like because he's a guy people just
accept it yeah I know I don't think
people accept it it's a hard but I think
as a woman it's more often that it
happens I don't know because men
are more likely statistics so I guess
I'm just gonna have to go because I I
don't really know enough to kind of
battle with you on there yeah yeah okay
I think I appreciate I appreciate your
knowledge like I understand that you
have more like knowledge
is it better to be a black person or a
white person in 2022 why
in jobs and everything like that if you
do like certain careers in University
you're more likely to excel than if
you're a bit of a black person but I I
also love him but I wouldn't change it
either I'm thinking more systematic
system so I'm fresh right so this is
about it's quite impressed you know it's
racism right like as in you can get a
job I could be a lawyer I could be a
doctor but getting higher in your
position really counts on the color of
your skin let's be real yeah and and not
not only cultural as your skills too but
mostly they are going to look at the
color of your skin and if you do get
into higher position most of the time
you are a token you know I I work in
violence we're drunk so forgive us
there's no right or wrong answer right
we're just having conversations but you
know I work in finance and you know I'm
doing decently for myself at the moment
right now there's no programs that help
white people get jobs like maybe white
women
yeah don't you think because that's
because I feel like that a part of that
is because they need to push it to show
that we're not racist and I don't know
if I'm a conspiracist or whatever you
want to call it like I do understand
they're like oh black women in power
like there was even like I think a
Barclays it was a bank I can't remember
which bank it was but there was a bank
that was helping women start business
and my brother sent it to me and I
remember it's like it's just like oh
black women in higher education but I
feel like a part of that is just to make
sure like the bank shows or like the the
government shows oh we're not racist by
the way like we do support black women
but unfortunately if you look at the
statistics black black people or people
of color are unfortunately poorer like
this is really scary because this is
what we were saying that um you know
black people probably statistically the
people at the bottom tend to be white so
if you go to the Northern parts of the
country they tend to be the poor areas
and those tend to be predominantly white
I think like they are trying in that in
the sense of all the programs helping
black people start like getting into
their careers and things like that but
additionally I think it's long overdue I
think that this should have been started
a long time ago so what do you mean by a
song Refugee like um we're in 2022 like
they should have been helping black
black people
um
do you think quotas are racist like
programs like specifically for like
black people are racist because it's
basically saying like you can't do this
on your own we need to give you a
special program
that is
[Music]
because of institutionalized racism it's
harder for us to do things on our own
like we will go to a job and there'll be
let's say five black people and five
black people I feel that it's a higher
chance of white people get the white
person will get the job than a black
person and I thought that these these
programs do enable us to further our
careers but I feel like wait as my
friend says we are in 2022 so I feel
like um this should have been long
overdue so I Ensemble you're saying
however when you look at universities
that tend to do these sorts of things so
if you go to Yale or the top
universities in America where they have
affirmative action a lot of black
students that get through um get through
to the university because of affirmative
action tend to do very badly because
they thought out of the depth because
obviously those are the top one percent
of people in in that country that are
allowed in that University and in
comparison the top 10 of black people
are in there might not be doing as well
basically teaching black kids to feel
stupid because they could be so smart
but they're at the wrong school go ahead
can I just say quickly like if a black
person gets them to yell or anything
like that they are a very small minority
of the University they don't have people
who are around them that looks like them
that acts like them that are able to
further them in their career they feel
like they're out of place so that sets
them down automatically I feel like yeah
also because in general out of the
population there's less black people so
of course you'll see less black people
at those institutions institutions
education I just feel like black people
are already like that's a whole new
level already at a lower amount or red
in the University as a whole when you
look at in a university as a whole it
needs higher education when you look at
black people and white people are
already a lower minority in the
beginning so when you as a black person
as we walk into a university and we see
less of our people we're gonna feel shy
we're gonna feel unable to come forward
and really voice off and that's and and
probably that's why most of the
universities now have ACS because tell
me what distinguished group you have for
white people you don't but then don't
you have to say like hey you're included
but don't you think that if there was a
group for specifically for white people
you'd be calling it racist no no no you
might not you might not but a lot of
people